BACK OVER TO HANNITY.
>> RIGHT NOW IS THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION IS HEATING UP, THE
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS ARE NOT
LOOKING FOR ANSWERS ON THE
STRONG BUSINESS DEALINGS,
DEMANDING THAT HE TURN OVER TO
THE WHITE HOUSE, SAYING THE
CONNECTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
SEVERE AND THE INFLUENCE HAVE
NOW BECOME ESPECIALLY RELEVANT
WITH THE RUSSIAN WAR IN UKRAINE.
AND TODAY THE FEDERAL PROSECUTOR
SAID IF THE INVESTIGATION
REVOLVED ABOUT ANYBODY OUTSIDE
HUNTER BIDEN THEY WOULD'VE BEEN
INDICTED, BUT THE CORRUPT
BUSINESS TRANSACTION EXTEND
BEYOND RUSSIA, MADE OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS SITTING ON THE
BORDER, HE AND HIS COMPANY.
AND HE TOOK A BRAND-NEW SPORTS
CAR, THE FORMER FIRST LADY OF
MOSCOW, AND $100,000 SHOPPING
SPREE OF THE CHINESE NATIONAL
AND OF COURSE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND OTHER
FUELS WITH CONNECTIONS AND ALSO
CHINESE INTELLIGENCE IN THE DEAL
AT THE BANK OF CHINA.
AND IT IS SAID THAT JOE BIDEN
LIED CLAIMING AGAIN AND AGAIN
THAT HE AND HIS SON NEVER
DISCUSSED A FOREIGN BUSINESS
DEALING.
TAKE A LOOK.
SHE MET MY SON HAS NOT MADE
MONEY IN TERMS OF CHINA.
THE ONLY GUY THAT MADE MONEY
FROM CHINA WAS THIS GUY.
THE ONLY ONE.
NOBODY ELSE HAS MADE MONEY FROM
CHINA.
>> ONE PUSHED ON THE ISSUE
DURING YESTERDAY'S WHITE HOUSE
BRIEFINGS, THE COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR DOUBLED DOWN ON HIS
LIES.
WELL, WHAT A SHOCKER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ABSOLUTELY STAND BY THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS.
I WOULD POINT TO THE REPORTING
ON THIS THAT WE GAVE TO THEM,
BUT AS YOU KNOW, I DON'T SPEAK
FOR HUNTER BIDEN.
>> JOHN IS WITH US AND HE'S A
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
JOHN, YOU PUT EVERYTHING ON THE
LINE.
YOU SEE INFORMATION IN THE
COURSE OF RECOVERING WHAT IS ON
THE LAPTOP THAT IS CONCERNING TO
YOU IN TERMS OF THE LEGAL ASPECT
OF IT.
AND ALL THE INFORMATION WAS
HANDED OVER.
CAN YOU TELL US WHAT YOUR LIFE
HAS BEEN LIKE SINCE YOU DID
THIS?
>> WELL, ONCE THE STORY WAS OUT
AND MY NAME WAS LEAKED TO THE
PUBLIC IT'S BEEN A MATTER OF
RUNNING AND HIDING AND NOW IT'S
TRYING TO REBUILD MY LIFE AND DO
IT IN A MANNER THAT IS NOT
RESTRICTED BY PUBLIC OPINION FOR
THE RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN.
>> THIS WAS YOUR BUSINESS.
WHY DID YOU CLOSE DOWN YOUR SHOP
IF THIS WAS YOUR BUSINESS?
>> INITIALLY THE MEDIA DID A
GOOD JOB.
CUSTOMER STILL COMING IN BUT
THEY DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY THERE
WERE ROTTEN VEGETABLES AND
PEOPLE STOPPED COMING IN FOR
SERVICE.
AND PEOPLE STARTED COMING IN
WITHOUT COMPUTERS AND I IMAGINE
THEY WERE THERE TO HARM.
SO I HAD MADE THE DECISION AND
THEN I CLOSED THE SHOP.
>> WHAT SPECIFICALLY ALARMED YOU
THAT THERE MIGHT BE SOMETHING
ILLEGAL ON A LAPTOP?
I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU EVER
ANSWERED THAT QUESTION?
>> WELL, I SAW A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WERE EMBARRASSING.
I SAW A LOT OF FINANCIAL
REFERENCE AND A LOT OF MONEY AND
THEN THERE WERE SOME OTHER
DOCUMENTS THAT I THOUGHT WERE
KIND OF STRANGE AS WELL AND THAT
INCLUDES WHITE HOUSE BRIEFINGS
ABOUT UKRAINE AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S TRAVEL SCHEDULE TO A
PRIVATE UKRAINIAN CITIZEN AND
THE NATIONAL SECURITY
RAMIFICATIONS ALONE WERE
DISTURBING AND I FELT THAT THIS
WAS DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT
HAD TO BE TAKEN TO THE FBI.
>> YOU ALSO SAW ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY.
THE PICTURE OF HUNTER BIDEN WITH
THE CRACK PIPE, THAT IS ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY AS WELL.
PICTURES OF A SEXUAL NATURE.
WERE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THE AGE
OF THE PEOPLE IN THE PICTURES?
>> NO, I DID NOT REALLY FOCUS MY
ATTENTION ON WHAT WAS SALACIOUS
ON THE LAPTOP.
MY BIGGEST CONCERN WAS THE
SECURITY OF THE NATION.
THE CRIMINALITY THAT HAD
POTENTIALLY TAKEN PLACE.
WHAT COULD HAPPEN AGAIN IF NOT
INVESTIGATED PROPERLY.
>> YOU KNOW, IT WAS
AUTHENTICATED BECAUSE APPARENTLY
HIS LAWYERS CAME BACK AND ASKED
ABOUT THE LAPTOP.
WE WOULD THINK THAT THAT WOULD
BE A DEFINING MOMENT WHERE THEY
WOULD'VE REALIZED THAT THIS IS
REAL.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THAT?
>> WELL, JOHN, I HOPE THAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
APPRECIATIVE.
DESPITE ALL THE STUFF THAT HE
HAS TALKED ABOUT IN HIS PERSONAL
LIFE, THOSE ARE THERE -- THERE
ARE THOSE OF US THAT DO CARE.
IN THIS COUNTRY I WISH THAT THEY
WOULD TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
WE KNOW THAT "THE WASHINGTON
POST" AND "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
ARE IN THE POCKET OF THE
DEMOCRATS AND THAT THEY WILL DO
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING TO GET
THEIR PEOPLE ELECTED.
BUT WE DO NOT HAVE U.S.
ATTORNEYS MOVING THE WAY THEY
SHOULD.
WHERE IS THE IRS.
WHERE IS THE FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES.
AND YOU KNOW, I COULD GO ON AND
ON.
WE EVEN MENTION ROMANIA AND THE
MONEY THAT WENT TO HIS GRANDKIDS
FROM THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI.
IN MEXICO, PROVIDING ACCESS,
THERE IS SO MUCH AND JOHN WAS
RIGHT.
HE PROVIDED IT TO THE
AUTHORITIES AND THE AUTHORITIES
ARE LETTING HIM DOWN AND LETTING
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY DOWN BY
NOT PURSUING THIS KIND PUTTING
HIM IN HANDCUFFS.
>> IT REALLY IS UNBELIEVABLE.
I WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS.
I'M SO SORRY THAT THIS HAS
IMPACTED YOUR LIFE REGULARLY.
IT IS AMAZING THAT DEMOCRATS
SUPPOSEDLY HAD PRAISED THE
WHISTLEBLOWERS.
AND YET YOU DID THE RIGHT THING,
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU HAVE DONE